well let's speak to the defense
secretary ben wallace joining us this
morning mr wallace a pleasure to see you
thank you for joining us
um even with this massive settlement 16
and a half
billion pounds the money is still not
enough it could be argued to
fill holes in the defense budget what
capabilities
will you have to cut first of all it is
enough
um you know it's actually if you take
our 0.5
manifesto commitment it's a 24 billion
pound a boost overall it's 16.5 billion
on top of
what we already committed in our
manifesto look it it is enough
um depending on how your ambition is
tailored you know i've been very clear
as defense secretary that
one of the failures of the past reviews
was our funding never maxed our ambition
and that that goes for most of the
reviews the last 40 years
this means that we can have a proper
discussion about what are our global
ambitions
and how we're going to fund it and this
very large settlement for defence will
allow us to fix the
problems that we've inherited the black
hole that the nao
uh obviously identified and allow
headspace to modernize
uh our forces and and i think those two
things go hand in hand
and then at the same time the prime
minister is very clear about what his
ambitions are
you know britain is a tier one military
power we are
a p5 nation we are a nuclear holder of a
nuclear deterrent
and we are the biggest spenders in
europe so i think you know that is all
about as tobias always said earlier
about do we want to be part of shaping
our destiny
or or do we want to follow on
um how much of it of this money is going
to have to come from the overseas
aid budget well the overall decision
uh for you know the whole of the
government budget will be obviously
revealed next week during the spending
review
announcement and the budget by the
chancellor and i'm not going to preempt
the chancellor
obviously uh you know the chancellor has
to find money from across
uh the taxpayer and the government uh he
will have made those decisions and the
prime minister will direct the
priorities so i think you know
what where it comes from is obviously uh
you know within that
total overall envelope i i think it's
not as simple as people might suggest
that you just raid one budget
to pay for another potentially a lot of
my budget is what's called capital
budget that's the same as sort of roads
and infrastructure budget
and that that is there are certain rules
around where those where that money is
and what that money is and how it can be
spent so
it's not as straightforward as we'll
just pinch a bit of this and pinch a bit
of that
it's mainly about uh the overall
envelope the chancellor sets
in conjunction the prime minister and
then the priorities picked
accordingly to the agenda
yeah except there is a finite budget
isn't it there's a finite pot
and as a result potentially some money
will have to come from the overseas aid
budget is that something that
you as you said it's up to the
chancellor is it something that you
would support him if he decided to do
that
well first of all part of britain's
overseed
assistance is defence and security you
know when i go abroad what many
countries want
from us is our knowledge our equipment
and our understanding of how to provide
security and how to provide defense and
you will find members of the armed
forces right now right across the world
assisting some of the most poorest
nations in defending themselves
from either islamic extremism or indeed
corruption
and that is one of the functions that
defense does we are a plank
in global britain we are a plank in you
know flying the flag for the united
kingdom and
you know that is one of our biggest and
most successful exports that is part
effectively of
overseas aid often when they come to us
what they want from us
is our security knowledge and expertise
and i'm very pleased
this settlement will allow us to grow
that even more you know i have a
defense diplomacy network of well over
90
uh officers spread out across over 90
countries
helping that and we'll continue to do
that
and in answer to my question what would
i support look
on this section of safe defense i need
to make sure that we have forces fit for
the future
uh we have forces that will be able to
deliver both defense and security and
indeed power projection for the united
kingdom
both soft power and hard power i believe
that settlement does that
uh it doesn't mean to say we are
abandoning the battlefield
of international aid well still one of
the most generous givers of
aid the actual decisions on the numbers
will be revealed next week and i'm not
going to
speculate how that's come about that's
for the chancellor next week to announce
the parliament
and if i were to ask you a third time
what
do i support taking money from it do you
support yes
there you go yeah you know
do i do i support more money for defense
yes i do that's why i put in for a bid
did i get it where it comes from is for
mata for the chancellor so
uh you know um we all want lots of
things in in life we all want lots of
things across the government we've spent
200 billion pounds
of taxpayers money uh responding to
covet so
uh you know it's really a matter for the
chancellor in the government where they
get the money from
i don't suspect it will be raided from a
whole load of other budgets
uh you know across the board it will be
taken as a result of of the measures we
can and and
you know how how we fund government is
obviously a mixture of
taxation borrowing or the obvious usual
routes
and that's a finite amount of money as
we agreed at the start cyber
and artificial intelligence when the
country is
um on its knees as we know financially
at the moment why now
well because you know i i spent the last
three and a half years being a security
minister and i saw every day
uh the threats arranged against this
country and one of the most
grow active and growing areas of threat
is in cyber for example
um where we see some of our adversaries
in the form of hostile states using
cyber against us whether
that is to use on organized crime or
whether that's to use to
to steal things or indeed just to close
things down we all remember that
wannacry
a cyber attack on our nhs we have to be
we're gonna be a 21st century defense uh
in a position to counter that
we have to be able to lend our knowledge
and support to other parts of government
so
for example child sexual exploitation
where pedophiles will use
high-end encryption uh to protect their
evil activities we have to be able to
use our knowledge
uh to hopefully stop that so cyber is a
really important domain
that we have to grow and expand into
because my duty is to defend the nation
as it is the prime minister's and
you know cyber's just one of the newer
growing domains and on space
we're all deeply deeply dependent on
space sky
sky news itself and sky as a channel is
incredibly dependent on the satellites
up in space and what we've seen is
russia and china are starting to put
weapons in space we've seen russia test
firing
missiles to to bring down satellites all
of that
means that we are very vulnerable if we
don't do something about investing in
the resilience
and defensive space to make sure that
you know today's 21st century
sort of west is protected from those
type of activities
okay that's quite a leap from uh you
spending all this money so that i can
keep my job
how much of uh the budget will be spent
on the cool stuff
like the space
and how much of it is going to be spent
on legacy stuff like f-35s and aircraft
carriers
it's going to be a blend so um on space
we already spent a considerable sum and
off the
of this money it'll be over 400 million
extra to take us to the next stage we'll
be
launching uh another satellite soon for
modern military communications
and of course there are other parts of
our space that i'm afraid
i can't talk about that are about
protecting our
critical national infrastructure so
there'll be a growing proportion towards
space
obviously we've got a space council
across the whole of government
uh and uh that amounts of money will
grow each year
as we put towards space and on the
national cyber force
that's giving britain the sort of world
leading capability of
offensive cyber so that's not just
defending but
being able to take action against our
adversaries that budget will be over 1.5
billion in the next four years
uh setting out uh you know what how
britain will defend herself
but also making sure we invest you know
over a 10-year period
you know okay over nearly 3 000 people
in the end of 10 years we'll be working
probably in the national
cyber force another couple of quick
points to rattle through if you don't
mind please defense
secretary we've heard what uh the
president of the united states has said
about afghanistan he wants to remove
his troops from there what are we going
to do
well part of this defensive view is you
know how can
britain be more independent so how can
we complement each other around the
world
but you know if one power or another
pulls out and we have a
you know we were for example gonna
decide wanted to stay longer
we could do so at the moment if if the
united states the unit actually pulls
out of some of these countries
we have a challenge we will have to
build a bigger or another coalition or
indeed we just have to effectively
uh you know follow them out and i think
that's something that no one has been
happy about
on the afghan initiative itself you know
men and women of the british armed
forces went to afghanistan
to try and provide security uh economic
stability and indeed deal with the
terrorist threat
many of them sadly lost their lives
doing that but
the goal was peace there is a peace
process with the united states the
taliban and indeed the afghan government
that's after what we went
to do that try and get peace it's it is
condition based uh we'll we'll see where
those conditions lead us but
fundamentally the united states are not
100 pulling out they're going to leave
a certain size of force in both
afghanistan and iraq we'll be working
with the afghan government
and the united united states to make
sure that we can continue to protect
this country
from terrorism and that means for
example for us we won't be pulling out
either the americans aren't pulling out
uh we're just making sure that the
conditions are going to be met for the
peace deal
and hopefully security will maintain
so it does sound as though we're
reducing our number then as well
well i think we'll see the details the
united states only just announced the
exact number that they're going to
reduce to
but i suspect if they're reducing at
some stage we will come down
we don't have a massive force compared
to them uh but we'll we'll do what we
need to do
to keep keep people safe and ensure that
we do our best to make sure that afghans
are kept protected as well
what we're going to do about iran are we
preparing for a preemptive
strike against iran and the dying days
of the trump uh regime
i think you need to direct some of these
questions to to the president look
look okay our view of iran is we support
the jcpo that's the
uh that was the you know pan national
attempt to make sure iran
complied with uh nuclear uh conditions
and in exchange there were
sanctions relief we still believe that's
the right thing alongside the french and
the germans
and actually it's one of the places
where the chinese and the russians and
us all agree together
um we think that's the best path for
peace and stability
we'll continue to support that uh you
know we urge both sides of the party
because the united states just to come
back and support the jcpo but also to
the iranians to make sure
they come in line and make sure they
stick to those conditions
i'm not sure i should be asking
president trump about our defense plans
but but there you go
let me ask you about uh locked up com
no no i mean you know you you refer to a
preemptive strike the the only media
reports have seen about preemptive
strike or iran have come out of the
united states
i mean it hasn't come out of the united
kingdom
no but my question was if it happens are
you planning for it
i'm guessing that we should be well the
the
the defense of the realm the united
kingdom constantly plans for
for hundreds of different scenarios
that's what you'd expect us to do
and that's why you see right now men and
women of the armed forces actually
out on the streets dealing with the
covet pandemic rather than uh you know
some of their other jobs that that is
what we do
all the time i'm glad you brought that
range of plans sure
yeah i'm glad you brought that up um
what what can we do to plan
for christmas um we keep reading uh in
the papers every day different things
about
how many people will be able to get
together for christmas the country is
absolutely
exhausted as a result of kovind 19. what
they need to do
is spend time with their family over
christmas and yet they still don't know
how many people they've been asked to
lock down again we've all been asked to
lock down again
uh coming out on the 2nd of december
maybe um
and then we're told that if we get
together at christmas then we have to
pay for
it with five days for every one day that
we come out of lockdown
what we need to know is how many members
of our family can get around the
christmas table
i'm the same as you i have a family i
would like to know that and i think
that's why uh over the next few days
uh the government will set out those
details you know the lockdown happened
about the 8th of november
uh we know that you know there is an
often a lag time between the lockdown
and how long it takes the
the the virus to spread or indeed be
flattened in its spread
and as we get closer towards the second
december we'll know more about the
the impact of this lockdown and
hopefully how it has slowed considerably
uh the flow into both hospitals because
part of that's what we're trying to
preserve make sure the nhs can cope
with the increase of of patients that
come in with covet
and as we get towards the second
december the government will therefore
set out all those different issues you
know we will
go into a tiering system i think our
aims are all the same
as you say we would like to see our
families at christmas we'd like to to
mix with each other as much as possible
but also we have to remember this is an
incredibly infectious
and nasty disease and you know there are
lots of people i'm afraid still
dying off covid the hospitals i'm a
northwest mp my constituency has been
literally in lockdown on and off
since july my family at home uh have
been
in a tier 3 before the lockdown in
lancashire
and you know that i know what impact
that takes on personal lives
but i also know that um you know we have
to try and sit on top of it because very
quickly our hospitals start to fill up
and people start to die in the in the
older groups or the more vulnerable
groups and that's
why we've made it secretary of state we
know that
we know we know and that's why people
have agreed to a second lockdown we know
all of that
what we want to know is how many people
can get round the table at
christmas and from how many different
households that's all we want to know
okay we will be able to tell you that
when we get towards the 2nd of december
when we know at that stage how many
people in the country
are affected what what's the
spaces in our hospitals uh how how the
rollout of vaccines is going to develop
we will know that much with much more
certainty around the second of december
than if you ask me today in the middle
of november so i can't give you
lots of those only two weeks away two
weeks
that's all two weeks you must know you
must have some idea
how this lock down is going look look uh
okay
if you are the one expert in the world
who knows how covid
has developed covid as we have seen
started with a virus that we knew very
little about
all of us all of us have been learning
as we go
in this virus if i sat here now made a
prediction about what would happen in
the middle of december
it would be highly likely that we would
get it wrong we wouldn't be
as able to cope as possible that's why
we are trying to improve the testing and
the tracing
and right now my men and women of the
armed forces
planning the vaccine rollout but i'm not
going to come in the middle of november
and set out uh exactly what will happen
in december
i think that is best close to the time
about the second of december
when we come towards lifting a lockdown
i'm sure every one of my viewers this
morning is raising their hands at the
telly and saying just tell us
how many people can sit round the table
you're talking about the middle of
november
it's the 19th you're talking about
december it's christmas
people need to know whether they can
move around the country
and whether they can see their loved
ones that's all they want to know
okay and people will be able to know
that about the second of december
i can't tell you now okay because you
know look
we know this i mean covid is
unpredictable
uh we take steps to climb shut it down
but we also know it's incredibly
contagious and that's why or infectious
and that's why
we need to make sure when we make the
decisions they are as close
as best informed as possible so we don't
have to do changes halfway through
and the best time to do that is closer
towards the second of december